مشاهدينا نستاهلوا المنتصف بالتطورات
الميدانيه المتلاحقه التي شهدتها الجبهه
الشرقيه في اوكرانيا وابرزها تسارع
الاحداث في مقاطعه دونيت فقد اعلنت كييف
انها صبنت نحو 100 هجوم في المقاطعه على
مدار ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وذكرت مصادر
عسكريه اوكرانيه ان المدفعيه توجه ضربات
عرقل تقدم القوات الروسيه في منطقه
في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها نجحت في السيطره على بلده او بيت
نوفي بعد عمليات هجوميه مكثفه شنتها على
القوات الاوكرانيه وفي مقاطعه زابولوجيا
قال قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان
قصف صاروخيا روسيا استهدف فجر السبت عددا
من البنى التحتيه الصناعيه اما خلصن التي
استعادتها القوه الاوكرانيه قبل اسبوع
تتجه اليها الدبابات ايرانيه ويجري توزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه على سكانها في ظل عدم
توفر الخدمات الاساسيه فيها وفق المصادر
الاوكرانيه
من جهه قال قائد الانفصليين المولين
لروسيا في مقاطعه دونيتك دينيس بوشيلين ان
القوه الروسيه تتقدم على طول خط الجبهه في
المقاطعه واكد ان القتال في مدينه صعب لكن
القوات الروسيه تحرر المدينه بيتا بيتا
وشارعا شارعا وافق تعبيره
نعم هو تقدم بطيء على عكس رغبتنا بتحرير
مناطقنا بسرعه رغم الاسباب والظروف
الراهنه نرى ان كل من طاقه بغض النظر عن
حجمها تمثل اهميه قصها لقواتنا كما لقوات
العدو التي تعمل كل ما باستطاعتها لصد
هجماتنا امامنا مهمه وقواتنا تتقدم كما في
اوبتني
دار ايضا ترون النتائج في ارتي
الوضع الصعب والعدو يدفع بقوات اضافيه لكن
قوات تعمل بشكل جيد ويتم تحرير المدينه
بيتا بيتا وشارعا نعم مع معارك صعبه لكن
منحنى التقدم تصاعدي